augustine romano donc j'habite à tandis
qu'aldi 64 ans donc si l'adjointe au
maire sur la commune du tampon et je
suis plus atteint 10,4 puisque je vis
ciel invite ici et au niveau du
département dont créé la délégation de
la protection maternelle et infantile
je suis élu dans le canton 25 et mon
attachement va écouter je suis né donc
j'ai vu l'évolution et que souhaite
continuer à contribuer à
l'épanouissement de ces secteurs
je pense en
rapprochant les services de proximité
plus près de la population
je veux surtout me battre pour l'emploi
donc développer encore plus peut-être
les chantiers les ateliers et chantiers
d'insertion et surtout affronter
accompagner les personnes âgées dans le
domaine du logement est en tout cas est
beaucoup plus près d'eux